uh
hello
so my strength is but we've all tested
oh
right
but it's nice for people who are online
okay
always
all right welcome everyone
i think we've got all the
streaming under control now so uh
welcome to the simons institute my name
is peter bartlett i'm the associate
director uh and welcome to the workshop
sampling algorithms and geometries on
probability distributions uh it's the
first workshop for the
program on geometric methods in
optimization and sampling i'm very very
happy to have you here
um a big thank you to the nsf for its
support of this program through the
foundations of data science institute
um big thank you to the organizers of
the workshop
excuse me diaconicolos uh philippe
rigolet and and santosh foreign so big
thanks to them
um so i'll hand over to eleanor in a
moment but let me let me just go through
a few logistics first um you've
discovered the the food outside for
breaks food and and uh coffee and so on
uh please don't bring those into the
auditorium
and and uh we'll have those
at the various breaks throughout the day
for lunches you'll be on your own
um please wear masks inside i'm sure
you've seen you've seen that request
for time and and any other time i guess
you can leave things in lockers on the
far side of the building on this level
um there are
pin numbers for for those lockers
um
everything's in a hybrid format so we've
got everything streaming on on zoom and
youtube
uh and
darren here's helping out with hooking
up speakers
uh computers and so on
and also uh big thank you to ashley
hassan
uh back here who managed all the local
arrangements for this workshop
all right so enjoy the week looks like a
fantastic lineup
thank you peter uh hi everyone good
morning uh i am jalen and diaconicolos
and i wanted to
wish you a welcome to this workshop i
want to start by thanking my
co-organizers philly prigolet who is
right here
and santosh venpala who will be here
later this week uh we also got
great support from the simon's
institutes to organize this and
specifically from
peter christine and ashley they helped a
lot uh so we have prepared i believe an
interesting schedule there's a little
bit for everyone so the topics uh
arrange from uh more
traditional theoretical computer science
work that is more on the random walk
side over
langevin dynamics hamiltonian monte
carlo particle-based sampling algorithms
and even talks that are more
on the side on
geometry of probability distribution so
not necessarily about sampling
we will also have a few talks that are
more applied
uh this is quite intentional because
most of us here are theorists and we
tend to work
on proving all these computational
bounds without thinking much about where
these problems come from so i think it's
going to be fun to see these talks there
is at least one
on each day wednesday thursday and
friday
okay so
uh one brief announcement on wednesday
we are going to have an open problem
session
so
please think about open problems you
would like to share with others and the
understanding is if you share a problem
that people will come and talk to you
about that problem
there are lots of breaks in the schedule
and that's also very intentional so that
you can easily context switch between
talks
we are running a little bit late with
the first talk
but in general i would like to
ask the speakers and session chairs to
make sure that for other talks we are we
try to be on time just so that people
can talk uh during the breaks
okay so it is a special pleasure to
start this workshop
with a talk by ravi kanan as
many of you know ravi has made many
seminal contributions to theoretical
computer science but in the context of
this workshop and in this program
ravi was one of the pioneers when it
comes to
computational guarantees
for sampling algorithms in particular
for random walks
back in the i believe late 80s early 90s
ravi worked on using
random walks the base sampling
algorithms
to
develop a polynomial time approximation
scheme for
approximating the volume of convex
polytopes now this is a very interesting
thing because
those problems are computationally hard
to approximate with deterministic
algorithms
and
what ravi alongside the dire and freeze
shown was that
if you use sampling algorithms you can
actually do this in
polynomial time of course polynomial 1
over epsilon and for this work
ravi and his old co-authors received the
full christian prize
so so it is amazing that he's here to
open this workshop he will not be
talking about random walks but
about uh clustering problems and the
title of this talk is how many clusters
and algorithmic answer
ravi thank you once again for being here
and please all welcome ravi kanan
[Applause]
uh
thanks for the intro um i'm going to
talk about something a little more
recently this is last year or this year
but yeah there'll be uh as you said
there'll be other talks survey talks
later in the week right
so there's a question of how many
clusters there are in a clustering
problem that's the title uh and we'll
give an algorithm to find the number of
clusters i'll just his joint work is
changing
i'll introduce the problem and why it's
interesting first
and spend a fair bit of time on that
but the uh clustering problem we have in
mind is the following i mean there could
be several versions but this is the
version we have in mind first of all you
have n points in euclidean space
distances are measured in euclidean
space right in our d d is a dimension
and we are promised this is what's
called a promise problem
we have promised that there is a nice
and i'll define nice there's a nice
ground truth clustering c1 through ck
because we don't know that plus string
our
job is first to find k exactly and this
is already a departure from most
literature where k is assumed to be
given a point that i will come back and
stress
and the ground clustering approximately
approximately means a small fraction
could be misclustered but k i insist
should be exactly found right no no plus
or minus one even
in in the answer to k
so data generated by stochastic mixtures
which is relevant to this uh workshop
and i'll come back to those is of is
something that fits this model where the
ground truth is which component of the
mixture you use to generate that that
particular data point right so data
points are clustered by
what uh component if it's gaussians
which gaussian did you generate as the
data point from
our results are general and don't assume
a stochastic model so we'll assume nice
will involve
no stochastic model only deterministic
conditions
but they will include a special cases
gaussian mixtures in fact all log
concave pdf mixtures and others
i i want to assess that previous
polynomials
generally there may be some exceptions
for special cases generally even for
special cases even for gaussian mixtures
assume k is given all right
that's our first point of departure
i want to introduce a lot of notation
but i introduce mu and sigma
mu and sigma now without reference to
probability just for any set of points
mu is just a mean centroid if you will
just the average of all of them
coordinate wise and sigma is a standard
deviation
maximum one in a 1d projection so you
take all 1d projections take the worst
spread and that's your standard
deviation of the set
okay so these are the two pieces of
notation that you you should remember
new ones to go with this this time
so the importance of knowing k and in
general
what's done in a lot of literature is
k gives you
an objective function like k means k
center
the many of them k gives you an
objective function and ever after you
specialize you you focus
only on optimization so it's a nice
clean mathematical problem and you
optimize
but then you have to be given k so k is
crucial for that
it led to a lot of nice algorithms of
course we have a lot of literature on
that including lloyd's algorithm and
beautiful heuristics for case center
now
uh more recently
um we know now
this is due to empower and rank first
that for gaussian mixtures
um
i guess i'm not defining mixtures you're
all familiar with that it's just uh
the probability function is a weighted
combination convex combination of areas
of the probability very various
gaussians right okay gaussians in this
case so if i tell you
something is a mixture of k gaussian and
i give you k
then you can project down to the k
dimensional singular value decomposition
space if you're familiar with what svd
is this will make sense otherwise
don't worry about it it won't actually
impinge on the understanding of the main
points this is what the literature does
right and and then you can you can work
in the projection and cluster that's
known but you need k at the outset to
know where to project
okay and uh
other results show that in fact you
don't need stochastic assumptions even
under deterministic assumptions still
need k
ah there's another class of algorithms
which is distance space clustering and
i'm going to state it very roughly this
is only a generic statement
you take there's some tau which is a
threshold and points a distance tau from
a data point or quote-unquote cluster
makes they belong to the same cluster as
the point
and you use this to classify lots of
bells and whistles this is just a
generic simple statement
you need a tau but you don't need k in
this setup right you just take tau as
you're cut off and then you get clusters
but
unfortunately this does not work even
for the case of a mixture of two
standard gaussians means
a constant number of standard deviations
apart
right
and it doesn't work because
inter cluster distances and intracluster
distances
get confused right points your cluster
mates may be farther than points
belonging to other clusters at this
separation
a simple thing to work out so
even though distance-based clustering is
used it's often used
assuming a huge separation between means
a point we'll come back to
not this kind of
six standard deviations or constant
number of standard deviations apart
now for gaussian mixtures there's been a
lot of beautiful work pinning down the
exact separation the exact sample
complexity and so on i caught a few but
there are many more but they all need k
even for statical gaussians
so there may be exceptions that some of
you are aware of but i'm not sure in any
generality you can we can later discuss
that but generally they all need kids
i'm spending a fair bit of time on
motivation because partly because the
technical details uh were or complicated
enough they'll take too much time so but
anyway i will get to the theorem and
state it precisely i won't give you all
the proof
but i'll give you ideas later but
still we are continuing sort of on
conceptual
part of the talk still
so the first assumption for niceness
is there'll be other assumptions you'll
see mean separation for every cluster in
the ground truth we assume the mean of
other clusters
is
a constant star is polylog factors
constant sigma of the thruster itself
array it's very important through the
talk that i'm going to measure distances
by quantities that i can
learn from the data
so
sigma is the unit here sigma is going to
be the unit of distance quite often but
sigma of that cluster itself okay so if
i give you the cluster you can find
sigma
sigma by the way is a spectral norm
calculation i
didn't say that but sigma can be
computed i'll give you a set of points
it's is the calculation of a spectral
normal matrix
okay so
means of
other clusters or at least so many
standard deviations of a most precisely
this is the bound we assume with some
log factors there and
this factor w naught is the mean weight
of a cluster that's always there in most
cases because you have a very small
cluster
it better be very far otherwise you'll
confuse it with other clusters
that's standard in all the separations
used
so here's a little picture that's good
to remember
two gaussians
omega sigma part the thing to notice is
data points are a distance root d in d
dimensions if sigma is one
right sigma's one then they are root d
away
but the separation is very small this is
a picture to remember schematic the
separation is tiny compared to the
distance of the points from the center
these big we'll assume these big we are
doing a synthetic analysis in d
this is typically something you better
be able to cluster
so uh the other other thing that's
happened about k is
uh
there are many heuristics
that
infer k from the k means cost by
plotting how the k-means cost looks as
you go up on k so the k means cos for
instance goes down as you increase k of
course
right
how it goes down you plot that and then
you try to figure out k there are
several ways of doing that
uh perhaps the classic method is
by
for instance hartigan i think it's in
the 70s i take the biggest drop
as you decrease k it's called the elbow
method there's no general proof and in
fact tell you that that doesn't work
even for simple cases
now under the assumption of a big drop
we can find the clustering there are
theoretical computer science results but
these big drops are not present in
general the drops amount of drop they
want is not present in general
there's a related thing sort of called
gap statistic for which we do have some
proofs um it takes the ratio of the
k-means cost to the one means but it
needs a prior and analysis is only known
for certain things like special
gaussians right
but here's a little fact to remember i i
won't give you these examples they're in
the paper
even for spherical gaussians it's not
true that the largest stop occurs with
the correct k
in fact for every integer there is a
mixture with that many components but
the largest drawback is that k equals
two and this is even for spherical
gaussian mixtures
again i won't give you the example it's
it's in the paper but but so you can't
go the elbow method doesn't work even
for statical gaussians in general
okay so here's a
example just to bear in mind uh one big
gaussian general gaussians let's say one
big gaussian small gaussians
these are separated
by
units sigma units right
and this is very large sigma c
and these are separated by c units
so
it conforms to mean separation
now the million dollar question here is
is k2
or is k6 k7 sorry
both are reasonable solutions
so what's clear okay so we'll come to
that
so conditions for nice ground truth
um
so we had mean separation that's not
good enough because
putting every point in a single cluster
by itself is consistent with mean
separation right if i put a point single
point in a cluster h sigma zero so you
don't require any separation and so
that's consistent we don't want that we
don't want to split points up we want
some sensible lower bound we'll have a
lower bound in terms of data i put an
arbitrary exponent here but n to the
minus point one is also all right
some polynomial than n
minimum weight assumption
now is that enough minimum weight and uh
separation now k equals one is still a
possibility so i have one cluster
mean separation is empty
there's no other cluster to separate it
from
and um
so that's legal and min weight is true
because i put everybody in one okay so
um if you want
even to be able to tell what k is from
the data even in not polynomial time
even an exponential time
we won't do just to have these two
assumptions we'll have to add one more
and that's a crucial assumption we'll
see
so usual fix
as i said assume k is given
so
this is a second
time i'm stressing this but i'll not do
it anymore theoretically k being given
helps in the following ways
it helps you define the objective
function as we saw and then reduce to
optimization
um
now k being given indirectly defines
what a cluster is which is sort of
unfair it would seem right it's sort of
cheating in some sense k is an
extraneous parameter which says number
of clusters
that tells you what a cluster is in this
example
ks2
makes all of these cluster mates into
one cluster k is 7 makes them all split
up so your k defines what a cluster is
which doesn't seem fair because k is
just an extraneous parameter you gave it
okay
and it we show in the paper and it's not
very difficult that in fact getting k
is empty hard even within very large
factors because coloring is reducible to
that again i won't do that practically
how do we know k
okay and the worst part of the
deal is in tcs talks people don't worry
about this
in theory computer science data is
somebody else's department so they have
to give us the data and we can
we can process it but we don't care
about how the data comes right so uh but
people ask
non-tcs talks people always ask me
how do you get k and the answer is um
i didn't know so far but here's this is
this is meant to address that question
right
okay so now i want to tell you the
important crucial third condition i want
to introduce by this very simple picture
so suppose i tell you the null
hypothesis is one gaussian d equals one
one dimension on the line i give you
data points another hypothesis is one
gaussian the h1 and the alternative
hypothesis is two gaussian mixture of
two gaussian is equal weight right how
do i tell the difference there are
zillion ways to tell the difference for
gaussians but is one way that i am going
to use
um i take
the pdf at every point
of the mixture
that pdf here
if it was one gaussian would be at most
one over root two one over two pi square
root sigma right that would have been
the case if it was one gaussian but in
the alternative hypothesis this height
is much higher than the sigma of the
whole thing because sigma the whole
thing involves the separation right half
the mass of half mass here sigma is at
least as much as that so sigma has gone
up a lot
but this remains one over square root by
the old sigma so the pdf is very very
large at some point
of the mixture
if it was two gaussians with one
gaussian it wouldn't be large if it was
one gaussian it's always going to be at
most one over square root of two
positive
against the gaussians
actually it's also true for outcome case
we'll come back to that
so
this is going to be the definition of
anti-concentration
anti-concentration
rules out you're thinking this example
was one gaussian i want to rule out
you're thinking this is one gaussian
whereas it was two right so that's
anti-concentration a set of s set s of
points satisfies anti-concentration
if the following is true so
i want to translate one over root two pi
sigma for pdfs into empirical statement
about a set of points right so that's
what this is doing
so
if i take
any line and project to the line
and take intervals that are not too
small
the most important point is this
the number of points in the interval is
proportional to the length of the
interval at most times sigma
this is true for a single gaussian
yeah
and it's not true for the pair of
gaussians well separated
let's just empirical version of the last
statement
by the way i have to take large enough
intervals because
since i have a point passes if i take a
very small interval this is not true
this is the prediction
uh clustering is finally nice if each
cluster has anti-concentration each
cluster has this behavior and mean
separation and minimum weight also hold
and the first theorem
is identifiability the main theorem is
an algorithm so what is identifiability
let me backtrack one step it's a
familiar notion machine learning usually
identifiably just means that
the data
only the data is enough to tell me what
the answer is the answer i want to know
is k
k is exactly determined by data this is
the number of clusters
so there cannot be two clusterings
with different number of clusters which
are both nice that's the first statement
and furthermore there cannot be two
clusterings with the same number of
clusters which are very far apart
here the distance is hamming distance is
how many points you must re-cluster to
get from one to the other
so this is really there's a unique
nice clustering
sorry there's at most one nice
clustering there may not be any nice
clustering there's at most one nice
clustering for any data yeah
so that should also depend somehow on
the number of points number of points
that you have in your data
yeah so
the minimum weight
tells you the number cannot be too small
but beyond that no
when we come to stochastic models yes we
need a sample lower bond we'll come to
that these are not stochastic it's all
deterministic
not a hard theorem it's it takes a few
pages but um
it's not immediate but
it's identifiability theorem says k is
pinned down by data no additional
information needed that's
identifiability means paper also
polynomial timeframe which is the main
result we'll come to that now
everybody with me so point wise upper
bound on pdf or
empirical version of that so the
algorithm is harder
there's another property oh sorry
i just wanted to understand some of the
geometry of your definition of the
cluster a little bit but it follows am i
correct in kind of concluding that this
assumption
uh included in itself the somehow that
geometrically they kind of have to be uh
roundish namely if i had two clusters
which are well separated but they're
let's see on line segments but they're
parallel line segments maybe a little
bit around them if i ever project to the
side where they are very concentrated it
will be much more concentrated than a
sigma because sigma comes from the
length then it would not recognize these
two clusters that's right i mean yes so
you need the sigma separation otherwise
so what can happen here is you you have
the well-separated case let's say two
gaussians as you move them closer
right they will stop being well
separated at some point
and you move them even closer
they will satisfy anti-concentration
because they'll become one but i just
meant that it's different in different
dimensions i could have something that
is geometrically well separated you know
this joint design but if one extent is
much longer than the other
then kind of the criterion that comes
from this sigma is applied to the side
okay i see what you mean you're
referring to the pancake problem which
is if you have two pancakes with very
large sigmas here very large sigma
and this does not handle pancakes right
okay i just yeah there's not now
we don't know how to handle pancakes in
any generality yeah we only know for
thousands let's try to understand what
this means
sure yeah it doesn't
handle
we don't take the sigma directional
sigma as the separating parameter we
take the max sigma off the component
though of the component that's important
not max sigma for everybody
so here's another version um
uh so
uh
this is also satisfied by two gaussians
against one so a set test of data points
is from one cluster if you will if it is
from one cluster the following is true
for every subset ignore this for every
subset the subset sigma is not much
smaller
there's at least one twelfth that's big
you do need the scaling factor as well
so it says that i have i'm pretending to
be a cluster i better not have a large
subcluster inside of me
um
the lemma which also requires a little
bit of work and some
vc type natural link displaced argument
but it's easy to show not difficult to
show that anti-concentration of the last
slide implies analysis analysis is
weaker
so here's the main theorem now we are
ready to state the main theorem
there's a polynomial algorithm which
given data with a ground truth customing
which is nice so it satisfies mean
separation it satisfies minimum weight
and
nlsc no large subcluster
this is weaker than anti-concentration
right so each cluster has the property
that it satisfies no loss of clusters no
subset of it is much tighter in spectral
law
by the way it's very important that you
work in spectral norm if you're working
for venus norm none of this is true
and then it finds k exactly and gt
approximately which is what we are
seeking to do
now corollary somebody so you asked me
this question about uh stochastic so if
you have a
stochastic mixture generating the data
now we assume
let's say anti-concentration
nlsc is enough but now we assume
anti-concentration of the pdfs
and we assume mean separation and
minimum weight
of the components of the mixture of the
generating model population
i assume assumption on the population
behavior right um we can find k exactly
gt approximately provide it and here
comes the statement about the number of
samples so you need this large number of
samples
so that the first
and second moment
empirically or close to the first and
second moment of the population
otherwise you can't apply this right so
i'm making assumptions about mean and
standard deviation
of the
pdfs
and i need to for the algorithm i need
mean and standard deviation conditions
on the empirical data and you only get
that if you have large enough amount of
data
right but large enough so
so here's a difference between tcs and
statistics perhaps in statistics
learning a stochastic mixture means you
get all the parameters of the
distribution
i don't mean that i mean you cluster the
points correctly
and then
it's again somebody else's department to
go find the parameters it's not mine
but
we need here samples enough only to get
the mean and standard deviation right so
if you have a general gaussian in d
space
the sample complexity is d squared to do
parameter learning i'm only going to
insist on d so that you get mean
i'm really confused with the difference
between this mlsc and the one that
sorry the i forgot what you called it
but the one that ensured uh
uh identifiability isn't the result
above saying that analysis is sufficient
to actually get uh identifiability of k
so identifiability
involves an exponential time algorithm
this result is polynomial time right is
that the question or no
well okay what i'm saying is this
recovers k right yeah i think there's
only one k oh absolutely
with a weaker condition so i just don't
understand the point of that oh
so why did i put up identifiability at
all right it's just a build up theorem
yes you're right this implies
identification there's only one case and
it implies also that the clr model is
right because i get the ground truth
right you're right
there's a stronger theorem than
i think i put up identifiability to say
that even identifiability was not known
before
that even data you can pin down okay
the proof is simple in the paper so that
we did that
so
um so you need to get the first and
second moments right then the clustering
can be done
for long concave mixtures you don't need
to explicitly assume 1k concentration
it's true all log concave pdfs certainly
gaussians you know one over root by
sigma is
set up as a giveaway
but it's also true for log concave it
may be four over so any log concave pdf
point twice is at most four over sigma
in any one dimensional projection where
it's a sigma of that one dimensional
projection that needs a proof but it's
normal
so uh is the main theorem clear so i
think i'm going to let's see i might
have about 10 minutes left is according
to my reckoning
so this is uh this is the main the the
determinate this is deterministic and
this is just an application of that
so i'm going to try to describe the
algorithm i was going to uh try to take
so much time for the motivation that we
don't get to this but we did get to this
so we'll describe the algorithm so i'm
going to describe first the algorithm
violating what i said that only the data
is given i'm going to assume w naught
the min weight of a cluster is given
that's much simpler and it's a
subroutine for the other things so i
might as well say that
so
if i take a set of data points
which minimizes sigma
subject to this cardinality bound
we can show that it's essentially
contained in a single cluster
so
if i can find such an s i would have
found what we can call the nucleus of
one cluster
then here's an attempt at an algorithm
find such an s
peel that s off
and then
repeat the process
and
you might get s from a same cluster or
different cluster it's got to be in one
cluster
basically
if we show that if s is close to one of
the already found s primes
then
it is from the same cluster as one of
the s primes we have to prove this we do
prove this
the important thing is these are data
driven quantities they are not extremely
similar
at termination we prove that you get
exactly k so sk is the correct number of
clusters you get that many s's so you
count them and that's your
that's your k
and uh it's also true after thought the
nuclear can be used also to grow the
actual clusters you can do the
clustering problem besides determining k
now very important again all steps use
quantity is determined by data plus w
naught the star contains some w naughts
but it's all known to you from the data
no extraneous quantities
except for step two this step
all are doable with some technical work
all these statements are true i won't
prove that i'll focus on step two and
i'm going to take a few minutes to
describe step two uh it's because an
interesting problem in itself
i want to find sigma among subsets of a
given size
uh given some data it's np hard as you
can imagine but what we give is a
bi-criterion problem
which gets the size of the set and sigma
both approximately correctly
okay that is the parliamentary algorithm
which
finds
we can fudge both these quantities in a
way i won't describe uh polytime to find
k given this w naught also and this is
used as a stepping stone to the other
one
so this is the exact factor don't worry
about that for now and this uses
semi-definite programming i'm going to
spend a few slides on this uh spectrally
tight subsets independent problem given
a set of points and an alpha
find an alpha fraction
so that
the spectra the sigma is
now sigma is is related to respect this
is spectral norm spectral norm for
matrix a whose columns are data points
offset by the mean
this is not difficult to see but we'll
assume that here right so i just have to
find a spectral norm calculation which i
know how to do
if you had frobenius norm it would have
been much easier but it won't do the job
um okay so
over there
yeah so i want to do at least strike one
connection before i quit
expand the graphs coming here
for spectral norms so
[Music]
okay so here's how they come in so
sigma is
just a spectral norm of that matrix data
points offset by the thing
now the mu s is an annoyance because i
don't know what it is
so instead there's another definition
which is pairwise take the difference
between every pair of points and take
the spectral norm of that matrix you
have to scale it a little bit
okay so let's look at this sum i take
data point i minus data point j and use
an arbitrary vector and take the dot
product squared and i sum over all i j
so here's a very
crucial observation if i have an
expander graph
with one vertex per data point
that does something for us what does it
do
uh there's something called triggers
inequality so a bunch of you are rapid
mixers you know what's going on
otherwise i won't have time to describe
it but tegas inequality tells you that
for every unit vector
the star
where the sun is taken over all i j is
upper bounded then i take the sum only
over the edges of the expander
instead of taking all tests i need to
take only the edges of expanded
so
a spectrally tight subset can be found
by just constructing an expander
where the sum is small expand the graph
now that seems difficult but there's
another line of work
it goes back to leighton and rao which
says
basically proves that every expand every
dense graph contains an expander
and in fact it can be decomposed as a as
a union of expanders
it's also used in clustering so
we need to find
can substitute expander by tens and five
so we need to find a dense graph
for which the sum is small but only over
the edges
and
so here's a semi-definite programming
problem uh i wonder if i
okay so one of these constraints ensures
this dense graph thing
um and again maybe i won't do that
okay getting by with just theta w naught
not given i'm going to try all possible
minimum weights
one they they come down in one over n
multiples of one over n i try all of
them when we hit the correct w naught
the previous stuff told us k would be
found
but what can go wrong before that i'm
going to give you an idea what can go
wrong and not so much how to fix it
recall our algorithm finds nuclei of
clusters there are three possible
failures
some nucleus has significant parts in
two different clusters
so the ground truth transferring one
cluster i'm sorry two different clusters
sydney
contributes significantly to one nucleus
that we found that's the problem
two different nuclei make it large parts
of a single cluster that's a problem
and the last problem is one of the
clusters may have been left out of all
nuclei but these are the only problems
why here's a statement
negation of one
one says some nucleus is a significant
parts of two negation of one says each
nucleus has at most one cl part
must have something because it's not
empty therefore there's only one cl so
that says that and negation of two and
three says the congress each cl is a
unique nucleus so there's a one-to-one
correspondence between clusters and
nucleus and therefore you find the
correct number
so there are three failures to fix
failure one is actually just nlsc fixes
it failure two
will not happen failure three is
actually more complicated and i won't
have time to describe it
but it's done in the paper so i have the
last slide then i think of the end on
time in practice higher this these so
fighting case this is a very uh there's
a first parliamentarian but it's very
expensive because svp is expensive and
more than that the separations are high
and everything is polynomial but high
fast algorithms other applications
respectfully typeset i'll leave you with
that maybe this i will mention in the
open problem session later
if necessary so that's it thank you
um so i actually didn't get the high
picture uh when you cannot find double w
zero n exactly
no okay right so
any approximation of that
should actually imply like if you have
an uh an epsilon approximation of that
it should i i thought it should imply
one plus epsilon approximation of k
so okay two things one plus seven
approximation of k is not good enough
right right okay that's one problem well
the other problem is i think it may be
true what you're saying that if i give
you
w to 1 plus epsilon then i might be able
to find the correct k
but i don't know that that is i don't
have a proof of that
w approximately may be enough right i
don't know that okay
but i i couldn't get why
even if because you're peeling
right so you you get you find the
nucleus you peel
and you continue
if you cannot get it correctly then you
are going to peel more
no because the pills are just nucleus of
the clusters i'm not peeling the whole
cluster off
right okay
it turns out i can but that requires the
extra one that is that is fixing uh 0.3
so it gets more complicated
are there other questions
i
got the question but you mostly answered
it and it it was about
in in
in some sense what happens if you do not
have a problem for which uh
all of these assumptions you're making
are
correct and you said there is the issue
of identifiability which
you know you need exponential time to
even determine but is there any do you
have any intuition
about uh
when you drop any one of the assumptions
whether the algorithm would still do
something reasonable or is there like
just nothing that can be said so
it's possible i don't know
but
what i do know is there are worst case
examples where the algorithm will fail
under dropping one of those functions so
they are in the paper so but these
always case examples so maybe it's true
that mostly the algorithm will do
something good
uh that may be true even without all the
assumptions i'm not sure
i see i suspect it's tough it can be uh
so it sounds kind of difficult like if
you dropped anything yeah if you drop
any assumptions i would suspect this
stuff
thank you very much let's uh thank ravi
again
[Applause]
so
let's do uh just a slightly shorter
break now it's 10 15 so let's all be
back at
10 22
and after the next talk there will be a
longer break
so see you all it's 10 22.
yes
[Music]
is
so if i take one knee
and fly the obstacle
[Music]
right